my name is Alan Davenport Wingard I had
graduated from from Kearney check in
1957 was a degree in organ performance
yes now not carnegie-mellon but
Shakespeare says wasn't a name I got a
letter from somebody in Greensburg PA
there was this pile of documents and on
top of it was the book from Carnegie
Mellon that notebook which I had
completely eclipsed from my memory was
found in a building that was scheduled
for being demolished it's filled with
musical ideas it's filled with homework
assignments from music theory this is a
working book this notebook
I mean a head exercising and
counterpoint and harmony Resnick's it's
going to take me a while to absorb all
of it it just blows me away wo w Wow
music is a perfect outlet for the
glories of the soul I'm so honored that
music has its way with me that flows
through me I can't imagine my life
without that it is totally totally a
grace a mitzvah its own it's not the
uncovering of this this book of
documents was just enormous Lee
surprising an enormous Lee valuable I
have many thankful moments of her being
a Music City student at Carnegie it was
a great benefit in my life I'm so
thankful that it continues to extend
benefits to the lives of all the people
there
you